hello and welcome to M coding where the
only limit is your imagination
and your download speed but mostly your
imagination in this episode we're
talking about python generators
including the yield keyword generator
comprehensions yield from and how all
this relates to async you define a
generator function in Python just like
you would any other function using the
def keyword and they can take parameters
the only thing different that makes this
a generator is the presence of one of
these yield statements somewhere in the
body
generators act like normal functions
except when you hit a yield statement it
pauses
every time you pause you can also yield
a value in this case Hello that becomes
available to the caller unlike with
functions calling the generator doesn't
run the generator
instead printing out the generator we
just see a generator object
the way you actually run a generator is
by calling its next method which is what
the next built-in will do
it will run the generator until it hits
a yield statement and return the value
at the yield statement
with every next call it resumes the
generator until it hits another yield
statement or until the function ends
if you resume the generator and the
function ends before hitting another
yield you'll get a stop iteration
exception raised
returning a value from a generator is
fine but it doesn't appear as the result
of a next call like the others do
the return value of the generator
actually appears as an attribute on the
stop iteration exception that's raised
this is mainly for a very Niche purpose
that we'll talk about at the end while
Ariana Grande might prefer to thank you
next next next over and over again in
Python it's more common to let a for
Loop do it for you
this works because under the hood a for
Loop we'll call that next function over
and over again until it finds a stop
iteration at which point it stops
check out my video on what a for Loop
actually translates to under the hood if
you haven't seen it already in any case
here we see the items printed out hello
world123
so what are generators good for
the most common use case for a generator
is to Define an iterator of a class
for a simple example consider this range
class
just pretend you don't know about the
built-in range and you're building a
range class yourself
in the spirit of being lazy like a
generator our ranges are all going to go
from zero to some stop value we don't
support start or step
so just like the built-in range which we
don't know exists range of five is the
numbers zero one two three four but when
we create the range we don't actually
store all those numbers somewhere we
just store the start on the stop
but if all we have is a start and a stop
how do we iterate over the elements of
the range that we're supposed to be
representing
the answer is the highly sophisticated
solution of counting
start at the starting value and then
continually yield the current value and
add 1 until we get to the stop
we can now iterate over our range just
the same as we would over the built-in
range
and just like the built-in range because
we're only storing the start and the
stop not all the numbers in between we
can construct huge ranges
there's no way a list of numbers from 0
all the way up to this number would ever
fit into memory
yet we can construct the range and
iterate over it quickly and efficiently
and to reiterate it's this laziness
where we're not actually constructing
those numbers until we ask to see them
that allows us to be able to do this
so while generators can be slightly
slower than lists in certain situations
if you're just processing them one at a
time like here we're just printing out
the current n then a generator can be a
huge win over a list and here's a little
history for you the built-in range in
Python 2 actually used to return a list
that turned out to be a huge mistake and
for Python 3 it was changed to be
something more similar to what the
generator is doing it's not actually
using a generator it's using something
handwritten in C but it's the same idea
another very common and useful place
that you might use the generator is
reading from a file
once again this is a situation where
because files can be so big you might
not want to read the whole file into
memory all at once
if you can process things line by line
using a generator then even if the file
is gigabytes big it doesn't matter
you'll only need as much memory as you
would need to process a single line
so for example I have some custom data
class in this case it's just XYZ points
my file just looks like this I just have
floating Point values XYZ XYZ XYZ
I don't know what's up with the red
squiggle pycharm thinks I have a syntax
error in my text file feel free to free
associate about what the problem is in
any case we Define a generator that
expects a file handle what I mean by
that is the file object that you get
back from an open call in a very
generator like fashion iterating over a
file actually iterates over the lines of
the file we strip off the trailing new
line and split it by the commas then we
convert everything to floats create one
of our custom data structures and yield
it and then we just print out the rows
of course you can do whatever data
processing you like
the next very common use case for
generators is to think about them as
lazy sequences you can Loop over them
repeatedly returning values so you can
think about those as values of some
sequence whether it be a mathematical
sequence like in this case or just a
sequence of objects and you just don't
compute the next term in the sequence
until someone asks for it so here's a
collat sequence take a positive integer
n if it's even divided by two otherwise
multiply by 3 and add one
then repeat if you ever got to 1 then
the sequence would start repeating it
would start to go one four two one four
two and so on as of 2022 it's one of the
world's most famous unsolved problems in
math
starting at any number do you always get
to one or could there be a sequence that
goes off to infinity or maybe some other
cycle like four two one four two one
well I'm here to announce that I've
actually proved the collapse conjecture
to be independent of the axioms of
mathematics
just kidding anyway here's what a
typical colad sequence looks like
it does some unpredictable stuff and
then eventually you hit a power of two
and it shrinks down to one this
showcases another very important
property of generators imagine if
instead of a generator we were using a
list well besides the fact that this
list might need to be arbitrarily large
because we don't know how long a collab
sequence will be what if I didn't care
about the whole sequence for instance
what if I just wanted to know how long
is it if you're wondering it's 111
elements but if I return to list in this
case that would have been a huge waste
why allocate all that memory and store
all those numbers just to get the length
if I wanted to be more efficient I'd
need to write another function that
calculates the length instead of storing
the list but that length function would
be basically identical to the list
function just instead of appending into
a list we add one to account
if only there was a way to have one
implementation of the collage sequence
that I can do whatever I want with once
again generators to the rescue if I want
the length of the sequence then I just
count one for every element of the
sequence once again we see 111 and if I
did actually want the whole list of
numbers in memory then I can just call
list on it generators can even be used
to represent sequences that we know are
infinite we can only ever use finitely
many terms but we're able to compute as
many as we need without specifying ahead
of time so you could represent all the
powers of two all the rational numbers
of Fibonacci Sequence or all the prime
numbers all you need is an algorithm for
enumerating them defining a generator is
as simple as defining a regular function
but you can go even simpler if your
generator is simple enough this is a
list comprehension which hopefully
you're familiar with and it creates a
list whose elements are x times x for
each X in the range replace those
brackets with parentheses and you now
have a generator comprehension this is
really just shorthand notation for
defining and calling a generator
function meaning this code and the
elements of this sequence will not be
computed until you try to actually
iterate over the generator and once
again this can be more efficient than
the list version which creates all the
elements in memory immediately if you
happen to be immediately passing a
generator into a function you can also
do it this way this creates a generator
just like in the previous line and
passes it to the sum function basically
it just lets you leave off a pair of
parens and now that we know about
generator comprehensions
another great feature of generators is
that they're extremely easy to compose
you can build pipelines of data out of
generators in no time suppose you want
to be able to parse a file like this it
has data in it that you want to treat as
floating Point numbers but you also want
to allow comments full line comments
nands Infinities and blank Lines no need
to write a fancy parser generators are
plenty expressive enough to get this job
done we start by opening the file and
iterating over the rows remember each
row is one line of the file strip off
the new line and remove anything after a
hash in order to strip trailing comments
then Define another generator that Loops
over the generator from the first line
all it does is filter out empty lines
each line should now contain a floating
Point number so we use float to convert
it from a string to a float then we do
another filter operation to throw out
any Infinities or nands then let's just
pretend that we want to replace anything
negative with zero and just for
something to do let's just say we want
to add up those numbers this was very
simple to write and easy easy to read
like a step-by-step instruction manual
on how to create the pipeline and once
again all this happens lazily so it's
very memory efficient
we've completely defined our pipeline
before we ever actually read from the
file at this line in the code we haven't
even read a single byte from the file
each next call inside the sum triggers
this generator to look for one more
element that triggers this generator to
compute one more element which triggers
this generator to compute more elements
until it finds a finite one which
triggers this one to compute more
elements until it finds a non-empty row
which triggers this one which finally
reads a line from the file so we're able
to process the whole file and we don't
even need more than one line at a time
in memory
and now we get to the advanced usage of
generators a yield statement is not just
a statement it's also an expression it
returns a value back to you and that's
because generators are not just possible
functions that yield values generators
are actually bi-directional pipelines
just like a generator can yield a value
up to its collar its caller can send a
value back down to the generator and
it's these sent values that are returned
from the yield expression
so here's how we read this we have a
worker generator the worker has a
collection of tasks initially empty
initially we yield none because we
haven't had any chance to receive any
tasks our caller is expected to send us
a batch of tasks the idea being that
we're supposed to evaluate the given
function using the arguments that the
caller passed to us if the caller passes
some new tasks then we extend our task
list with those arguments otherwise we
assume that the caller is asking us to
complete a task
so if there's a task available we pop it
off evaluate the function with those
arguments to get some value which then
gets yielded back out to the caller and
here's how a caller would use the worker
so our worker is just going to convert
whatever arguments we give it to a
string we use the send method to send
values into the generator however when
we just create the generator it doesn't
start running it the very first value
that we send can't possibly be accepted
by the worker because the function is
going to start at the beginning there's
no yield statement there so first we
just send none to cause the generator to
run to the first yield just like a call
to next send will cause the generator to
run until yield or until the function
returns after the send none the
generator will be paused here so now
we'll send in three tasks the number one
the number two and the number three
these are wrapped as single element
tuples because we're processing them
using star args now if we call next
three times then we'll see our three
values evaluated when use the next call
the return value from yield is going to
be none we can send in more values and
then print them out and that's part of
the usefulness of this setup I can add
tasks or evaluate tasks at any time I
don't need to have everything prepared
ahead of time and I don't need to
compute all the answers at once and
another thing you can do is use the
throw method to throw an exception
inside the generator as you can see the
exception acts as if it was thrown from
the yield statement so you could
surround this in a try except if you
wanted to handle exceptions that way
there's also the close method that does
basically the same thing as throw except
it throws a special generator exit
exception
this exception gets special treatment
and it's basically a way for you to
cancel the generator without having that
error propagate up so at this point this
should feel very familiar to something
else in Python
we're basically submitting tasks into
this worker thing and then something
drives the worker and the worker decides
how the tasks are scheduled and when to
actually call the function and do the
work doesn't that sound a lot like async
I don't expect you to already know all
about async don't worry I've got a video
on that coming but just the general idea
of defining tasks and pausing functions
and continuing later when things are
convenient well it's no coincidence as
it happens under the hood in Python
async await co-routines are defined in
terms of generators
so once again being lazy is paying off
big time the lazy Machinery of
generators is powerful enough to design
an entire async framework around
and that's not even the end of the video
because we still have one major feature
of generators left to cover yield from
yield from allows one generator to yield
values from another generator
in most cases you could use it exactly
like you would a for Loop looping over
the values and yielding them
and that's totally fine there's nothing
wrong with doing that using yield from
is going to be one line shorter and it's
going to avoid using an extra local
variable
however
that's not the intended use of yield
from and it's not why it was introduced
into the language
just think about it do you think they
would really introduce a whole new set
of keywords just to have a shortened for
Loop the true purpose of yield from was
that it was introduced into the language
in order to facilitate the
bi-directional nature of generators
remember a caller can receive values
from generators but they can also send
values to generators
but what if a generator wants to take
the values that it receives from its
caller and pass them to a sub-generator
for instance here's a quiet worker
it's another generator because it has a
yield and all it does is it creates a
worker and then yield from allows the
worker to pass messages from its caller
directly into the worker and likewise
whatever the worker yields is yielded
back up to the caller if a task causes
an error
the quiet worker just catches it and
then creates a new worker to keep going
this is of course Very Bad practice
because the task queue of the worker may
not have been empty
but we're throwing it out and creating a
new worker anyway
in any case the yield from is what
allows us to pass messages
bi-directionally
it essentially acts as a pass-through
taking whatever messages from our caller
and passing them to the worker and
taking whatever messages from our worker
and yielding them up to the caller
that is the true purpose of yield from
the fact that you can use them to write
one line shorter for Loops is just a
bonus
oh yeah and just like yield yield from
also returns something it's the return
value of the subgenerator
that thing inside the stop iteration
from the beginning of the video this is
its real purpose
so there you have it that's all I've got
on generators I hope you learned
something I hope you enjoy it let me
know in the comments how much you want
me to make that async video
if you really enjoy my Channel please do
subscribe and consider becoming a patron
or donor as always don't forget to slap
that like button an odd number of times
see you next time